the words ancient greece conjure certain
associations and ideas to many people
democracy philosophy science and
rationalism are some of the concepts
that come to mind
the great thinkers of ancient greece are
portrayed as enlightened rationalists
whose approach to knowledge was similar
to the prevailing tendencies of our own
age forefathers even to an enlightened
intellectualism that was hindered during
the middle ages and revived with the
developments of modernity but this view
does not really hold up to historical
scrutiny we find that this view of the
ancient philosophers is often an
anachronistic way for us to sort of
project our own ideas and ideals back
onto idols of the past it says more
about our own times and ourselves than
it does about the ancient greek context
for example as it were and in this
series of episodes i hope to paint a new
picture of this world one that is more
historically accurate and also takes
into account the full spectrum of
nuances in great thinkers like plato for
example and we'll find that while
rationalism is often very important to
these people
it's a lot more complicated than that
too and other aspects of like what we
would call mysticism or even esotericism
are sometimes equally as important we
have already talked about the
fascinating pythagoras in an earlier
episode and today we're going to turn to
the incredibly interesting world of the
ancient mystery cults in particular
we're going to talk about the probably
most famous and popular of these
mysteries in the ancient world which was
the elusinian mysteries and how its
transformative mind-altering rituals
served as a central part of religion and
society in the ancient hellenic world
[Music]
the mystery cults of the ancient world
is a fascinating topic one that is key
to understanding its complex religious
landscape but also a topic that is
frequently misrepresented or
sensationalized
the mysteries are of great interest not
only to scholars but also to occultists
of the modern age people involved in the
so-called western esotericism and the
new age movement the mystery calls are
in fact a very complicated and difficult
subject to define because as the term
suggests there were many of them and
they could look quite different from
each other the demographics nature of
its teachings or rituals varied and
existed in a wide geographical span
especially in the hellenistic and roman
periods but in very generalizing and
brief terms the mystery cults were
rights of initiation
often associated with a specific deity
at its center the mystery cults often
offered a
ritual experience that would transform
the life of the initiate in radical ways
bringing benefits in this life or indeed
being key to a kind of salvific
afterlife as well another common feature
is that these rights somehow represented
and enacted a spiritual death and
rebirth of the person through this
intense experience
again these are generalizations but are
some common characteristics of this vast
phenomenon and the most famous popular
and one of the oldest of these mystery
cults are the so-called eleusinian
mysteries which were centered on the
worship of the goddess demeter and her
daughter persephone also sometimes known
as corey
this was an annual festival that took
place in the town of elusis a few miles
outside athens where all of its
activities were exclusively based
at the height of its popularity hundreds
or even thousands of people would have
taken part in the rights and become
initiated into these mysteries
in essence thus the mysteries is
something that you partake in once after
which you are initiated and become part
of the community whose lives have been
transformed by the ritual
but you know in actual practice you
could of course perform this initiation
ritual several times and many people did
and and so that was a common practice
the problem with the cults at elusive as
with most mystery cults is that we know
very little about what was actually
going on there and this was on purpose
the secrets of the mysteries were not to
be disclosed and could not be disclosed
it was all kept under a blanket of
secrecy and silence a silence that
indeed was very well kept now there are
some stories of individuals who publicly
revealed some of the secrets such as
diagrams of milos and they were exiled
or tried as a result showing you how
seriously they took the whole secrecy
thing
so this leaves us with a lot of educated
speculation on the scholars part but
indeed we do have fragmentary
descriptions from various writers that
mention
parts of what went on and give us
tidbits here and there so that we can
i guess sort of piece together some idea
of this elusive cult figures like the
platonist philosopher plutarch who seems
to have been an initiate himself gives
us fascinating descriptions of the
mind-boggling experiences had the
christian father clement of alexandria
seems to have had some kind of
first-hand knowledge of this stuff and
gives us some valuable information too
even if he is a critical voice being a
christian writing in later periods
looking back back at his sort of sinful
pagan days and we even have indications
in the writings of plato himself that
seem to allude to the mysteries and much
else
indeed the illusionian mysteries were a
major affair it wasn't some small
secretive cult operating in secret as
some sometimes assume it is claimed that
perhaps the majority of adult athenians
were initiated into the cult and had
even received state support so anyway
with all of these obligatory disclaimers
out of the way what can we actually say
about what went on in the illusionian
mysteries again we are essentially
dealing with an annual event one that
involved a number of stages and
elaborate rituals the festival took
place in late summer around september
and would last for 10 days in total to
open the festival the participants or
future initiates would purify themselves
by bathing in the local waters and then
rituals of animal sacrifice were
performed by priests
and this was a kind of way of opening
the whole festival after this on the
fourth day they would all start walking
the whole 22 kilometers from athens to
ellucis on foot
on the way the procession would sing
songs in unison and swing branches
called bakoy
this would have been a rather intense
journey especially in the summer heat
but it was only the beginning of the
proceedings because once the group
arrived at the destination they would
also fast for a full day while also
continuing to perform various rituals
such as all night vigils as we will see
the purpose of the whole ceremony is to
induce intense altered states of
consciousness in the initiates and all
these aspects so far come off as
preparatory techniques to make the
person more susceptible to those kinds
of experiences like the fasting for
example we see this in many other
rituals even today
which involves mind-altering experiences
that you fast for example before a
certain which will take place so
many many of these things sort of point
to that direction that this would make
the initiatives more susceptible to
altered states of consciousness to some
this becomes even more clear when we get
to the next step which is to break the
fast with a barley drink known as the
cookie on
the ingredients of this drink is a
subject of debate among scholars and we
don't know much for sure
many will of course argue that it may
have contained some mind-altering or
psychedelic compounds and that this
became a central part of the ritual at
elluses but others also disagree or at
least don't want to conclude anything
based on speculation only because there
is after all no direct evidence that any
mind-altering substances were used in
the eleusinian mysteries other than wine
so it depends on how careful you want to
be there is certainly a possibility that
it did contain some wacky stuff and
there are other indications pointing to
this like the fact that demeter the
central deity in the ceremony is
depicted with poppies but there are
other interpretations for this as well
in any case the kyukian drink was
consumed to break the fast and just
before the main ceremony itself started
at this point the initiates referred to
as mustai which is actually where we
eventually get words like mystics would
enter a large hall called the
telestereon and would come out a few
days later completely transformed by the
experience in that room
what actually went on in that place is
still very much a mystery
like we said earlier initiates were
forbidden from telling anyone what went
on and this secret appears to have been
kept really well for the most part
it forces scholars to have to make a lot
of educated guesses and piece things
together based on the accounts that we
actually do have we can be pretty sure
that it was very intense and that in a
general sense the initiate would be led
by the priests through rituals that
induced altered states of consciousness
which could reveal truths about the
divine myths or about reality itself
these altered states which are referred
to in greek with terms like manila or
bacchaea meant an aesthetic
transformation of the person that had
lasting effects for the rest of his or
her life and meant that they were now
initiated into the mysteries now at the
center of the eleusinian mysteries is
the myth of the goddess demeter and her
daughter persephone also known as corey
in this famous myth hades the god of the
underworlds is enamored by the beauty of
persephone and is given permission by
zeus to take her as his bride
so one day when the goddess is out
gathering flowers hades suddenly emerges
from the ground and abducts her bringing
her down with him and making her queen
of the underworld
her mother the goddess demeter is beside
herself when she realizes persephone has
gone missing
she searches all around the world but
cannot find her
being the goddess of harvest and
agriculture the meter then causes
everything in the world to stop growing
the earth doesn't produce anything
anymore which puts humans and gods in a
real pickle humans start to starve
obviously and neither can they make
offerings to the deities
eventually though the sun god helios
helps demeter by telling her what
happened and because of the disaster her
despair has created zeus forces hades to
return persephone to the world of the
living but hades tricks her at the same
time and forces her to spend a few
months each year in hades and the rest
of the year with the rest of the gods
this obviously is then a mythical
account of the turning of the seasons
the time that persephone spends in the
underworld is of course the winter
months when things stop growing and her
triumphant return to the world is the
triumphant return of spring and summer
but in the elusian mysteries this myth
also comes to symbolize significant
aspects of the ecstatic spiritual
experience
the descent into the underworld and
subsequent return is reenacted by the
initiates through a kind of spiritual
death and rebirth throughout the ritual
they are plunged into the darkness of
despair and death perhaps even
experiencing something like a near-death
experience and they thus experience
firsthand the pain of demeter
but this darkness is then followed by an
ecstatic rebirth as the initiate takes
on a new life one with a newfound
understanding of death and the world
generally
whatever went on inside the telestereon
it was all aimed at inducing these kinds
of altered states within the initiate
julia ustinova writes quotes mystery
rights were intended to unsettle disturb
and horrify as only in absolute contrast
to the initial terror could the initiate
arrive at profound modification of his
attitude to life
but how exactly was this achieved
clearly this stuff was very elaborate
and included many stages and parts from
the scary death-like initial experience
to the ecstatic culmination when the
initiate reached transformation and even
an experience of uniting with the god
what we do know is that there is
reference to three aspects or elements
to the ritual
number one the dramana things done
number two the dec numina things shown
and three the legomena things said what
does this seem to indicate
i must agree that things done refers to
some kind of reenactment of the myth of
demeter and persephone things shown seem
to indicate that certain sacred objects
connected to the myth were revealed to
the initiates and things said are words
or phrases or even explanations of the
meanings of these objects
you can see that the myth is at the
center of the proceedings but aside from
these there seems to have been many
other factors
sounds movements and sensations that
helped induce a certain state of mind
for the initiates that made these things
incredibly intense
there was a group of priests both men
and women who seem to have led the
proceedings and groups of previous
initiates would sit on the sidelines of
the hall watching the ritual unfold like
was a performance of some sort
one other such factor may have been
music we all know that music can have a
very strong impact on our state of
awareness and that many spiritual and
quote unquote mystical traditions around
the world have employed music in various
ways
the illusionian mysteries seem to have
been no different
during the ritual there would have been
instruments playing and probably intense
dancing which would have led to ecstatic
states the power of music and dance to
alter states of consciousness has been
well known to people across history and
even someone like plato seems to take it
for granted whatever went on inside the
telestereon it's clear that it was very
profound initiates may even have been
subjected to physical pain being
blindfolded and other factors that led
them through experiencing a kind of
dying
as we said in many ways the ritual seems
to have been a kind of death and rebirth
after going through the painful
experience of death although not real
death of course the initiate would then
ideally enter a state of ecstasy a
feeling of immortality and even of
uniting with the divine this peak was
often accompanied by a vision of pure
light and a feeling of transcendence
the experience at elusive was clearly
very powerful as
people who had gone through it report
that their lives are changed completely
after this experience having a
completely new perspective on life and
death and many even report that they
lose their fear of death entirely the
scholar walter berkert writes quote
mystery festival should be unforgettable
events casting their shadows over the
whole of one's future life creating
experiences that transform existence
that participation in mysteries was a
special form of experience a pathos in
the soul or psyche of the candidate is
clearly stated in several ancient texts
one of the most profound accounts of the
experience of mystery initiation comes
from the famous platonist philosopher
plutarch who himself appears to have
been an initiate
he says the following caught
at first there was wandering and wary
some roaming and some fearful journeys
through unending darkness
and just before the end every sort of
terror shuddering and trembling in sweat
and amazement
out of these emerges marvelous light and
pure places and meadows follow after
with voices and dances and solemnities
of sacred utterances and holy visions
among these the completely initiated
misters walk freely and without
restraint
crowned he takes part in rights and
joins with pure and pious people he
observes the crowd of people living at
this very time uninitiated and
unpurified who are driven together and
trample each other in deep mud and
darkness and continue in their fear of
death their evils and their disbelief in
the good things in the other world
then in accordance with nature the soul
stays engaged with the body in close
union thereafter
he is clearly describing some very
powerful out of body experience here one
that transforms the soul of the people
who go through it now of course we can
assume that everyone who
went through the lucidian mysteries had
this same experience but at the very
least it's clear that this
ritual and the the things that happened
in the telestereon have the ability to
lead to some serious altered states of
consciousness the illusionian mysteries
were a major part of religious practice
in the ancient hellenic world as we said
at the beginning a lot if not the
majority of athenians so people living
in athens and the surrounding region
were initiates and took part in this
festival on an annual basis
it lasted for centuries if not even
millennia which is attested for example
in the fact that both plato and plutarch
refers to it as sort of a contemporary
practice and they lived almost half a
century from each other it was of course
only one among a multitude of different
mystery rights in the ancient
mediterranean world but it's probably
the most famous
it lasted basically all the way until
the spread of christianity a religion
that of course doesn't look too kindly
on things that is so
clearly connected to polytheistic
religious practice and belief and so
with the spread of christianity and the
fact that it became the official
religion of the roman empire eventually
the eleusinian mysteries closed down
sometime in the 4th century a.d but
before that time it had remained a
cornerstone of religious practice in
ancient greece and represents a
feature of that religion and culture
that i think not too many people are
that familiar with alongside the
rationalist writings of people like
aristotle or plato these same people
were often also deeply involved in
religious practices that many today
would call mystical and and they
consider that to be an equal or even
superior way of reaching knowledge about
the world and its philosophical truths
it's an important reminder that we often
project our own time back onto the
idealized past and that there's a lot to
learn about some of the most famous
figures in history
in future episodes we will continue to
explore this world there are other
mysteries to uncover more philosophers
and religious figures to get to know and
text to study for now i hope this was an
interesting introductory look into the
illusionian mysteries it's a really
fascinating topic to study and it's a
privilege for me to share
this topic and this this passion with
you out there i really appreciate all of
you watching and engaging in this
community and in these episodes it's a
wonderful honor for me to be able to do
this with that said i of course would
like to as always thank all of my
patrons who help keep this channel going
uh i say this every time but i'll say it
forever i could never do this in in the
way that i am doing it without your help
so thank you all so much
uh again look forward to more videos on
related topics like this one and
feel free to like the video leave a
comment or subscribe to the channel
and i will see you next time
[Music]
you